قال كل من تحدثت
إليهم تقريبًا إنهم فوجئوا برؤية هاري
وميغان وقد
قابلت بالفعل امرأة شابة
تبلغ من العمر 14 عامًا فقط كانت هناك مع
والدتها وكانت في الواقع تعانق ميغان
وسألتها عن ذلك ،
استمعنا فقط.  لقد
جاءت وقربت مني وسألت عن
اسمي وكيف كان يومي كم من الوقت
كنت أنتظر وسألت إذا كان بإمكاني أن أحصل على
عناق فاحتضنتني مرة أخرى حتى
كانت تلك لحظة رائعة جدًا ما
زلت أرتجف  الآن
لا أستطيع حقًا أن أشرح ما
كان عليه الشعور عندما فعلت ذلك ، لكن كان من
الجيد حقًا لماذا شعرت أنك
تريد أن تعانقها لأنني لا
أعرف أن الأمر قد مر في ذهني تمامًا كما
كان الجميع يهتفون نوعًا ما
أنا الآن وأعتقد أنني شعرت أنني بحاجة إلى
ذلك بطريقة مثل أنني أردت حقًا أن
أعانقها على الأقل لأنني نظرت إليها
من بعض النواحي وشعرت أن هذا
هو الشيء الصحيح الذي أشعر به
إنها تمر بالكثير ، نعم
بالضبط لأنها مثل هذه الأمراض المنقولة جنسياً  لا يزال
هذا أمرًا محزنًا يحدث
الآن ، فلماذا تشعر ببعض التعاطف
معها لمجرد
وفاة الملكة أو بسبب علاقتها الكاملة
بالعائلة المالكة أعتقد
في كليهما بسبب وفاة الملكة.
وأيضًا بسبب كل شيء ، لكنني
رأيت أنني أشعر أنها كانت لطيفة
جدًا لرؤية وليام وكيت وميغان
وهاري معًا وكان الأمر جيدًا ولكن
نعم أردت فقط أن أظهر لها
أنها مرحبًا بها هنا على ما أعتقد
وأريد  للتحدث بعد كل ما
حدث الآن حقًا ، هل
تفاجأت لأنني ربما كان من غير المفاجئ
رؤية الإرادة وكيت هل كنت
متفاجئًا برؤية هاري وميغان
معهم ، لقد فوجئت حقًا بمجرد أن
رأيت مثل لأنني رأيت ميغان وهاري
مثل هناك وبمجرد أن
أراهم كنت مثل يا إلهي
لأنني لم أكن أتوقع أن يكونوا هنا حقًا